Good morning, John.
today I want to do something a little different
that might not be appealing to everyone. I'm
going to make a video about making videos.
And of course, if you don't care about making
videos, I'm going to do my best to make it
entertaining nonetheless.
Ok, first let's talk about what I'm not going
to do, I'm not going to talk about your equipment.
I don't care what kind of camera you have!
I don't care what kind of computer you have
or what kind of software you have! This is
not about that! I believe that skill is honed
by lack, and there's no reason to have a sword
made of Valyrian steel if you're just learning
how to wield a knife . So let us talk first
about what's actually important, which is
how to look and sound.
Important Thing: The Rule of Thirds. Divide
your screen into thirds this way and this
way. One of the interesting things about vlogging
is that early on both the eyes and the mouth
were falling on those lines, but now that
screens have gotten a little bit bigger, generally
it's just the eyes that are falling on the
line, because the eyesónot the mouthóactually
are the most important element of your frame!
I think that says something fundamental about
human nature. I'm just not sure what it is.
Now, how you sound. Imagine for a moment me
going downstairs and talking to my wife the
way that I talk while I'm vlogging. That does
not happen! This is not my normal talking
voice. Surprise, surprise! The way that I
imagine it is that I am on a gigantic stage,
and there is one person in the audience, and
I'm talking to that one person, but I can't
talk to them like a normal person 'cause I'm
on a gigantic stage!
Now this is obviously a difficult thing to
hone; you're not going to get your vlogging
voice immediately. Watch early vlogbrothers
videos and see that we sucked too when we
started. It's nice for me that the one person
in the audience is generallyóor at least
started out beingómy brother. So I knew how
to talk to my brother; I knew what would make
him happy. Now that one person has changed,
and it's kind of an amalgam of all of Nerdfighteria.
It's just each of you individually I'm trying
to imagine all at once; it's very strange.
Now moving on, there's Don't Forget To Be
Awesome, which is one of the most important
rules in life, but there's also, for vlogging,
another one: Don't Forget To Be Interesting.
I even write out scripts sometimes, so that
I make sure that what I'm saying...isn't dull
as hell. I wrote a script for this video;
I'm going to post that script on my Tumblr
so you can see the difference between the
script and what actually gets made into the
video.
Also never forget that even the best audience,
there will be parts of it that will have a
very short attention span, and you will have
to pander to those people. But honestly, it's
fun, and I truly believe that pandering to
those people actually makes your video better.
There's a lot of ways to keep things interesting,
you could move around, put some video over
your voice. You could use props; awesome,
funny hats. Go outside! You can sing, you
can sing songs. You can speed things up, or
you can slow things down. Use filters, and
you can use puppets. A lot of times people
ask me how I get ideas for videos, but really
it's not about having ideas for videos; that's
easy. Mostly I'm trying to figure out how
to make those ideas interesting.
Another very important rule: Silence...is
extremely powerful! Use it very sparingly.
If you watch one of my videos you will notice
that there are very few moments that do not
have sound in them, and that is especially
true of the space around jumpcuts. Any silence
around a jumpcut is bad bad bad bad, BAD!
Another important rule: Do not be afraid...to
try! I know that failing at something stings
a lot less...if you didn't really try hard,
but, it's also much more likely.
And finally, let's talk about editingóno
we're not going to do that because that would
take forever, so instead I am literally going
to post a screen capture of me editing this
vlog. I'm gonna put that on my second channel
at youtube.com/hankschannel, hankschannel!
And you will be able to see how I made this
video, how I did all the tricks in this video,
and all the things that I do to make my videoblog
seem...professional, and crisp, and good,
and entertaining, and all of those things.
So that's how you vlog! Of course, you can
do it however you want to do it, but I figured
people might be interested in seeing how I
do it. I encourage all of you to vlog, and
I encourage you to do it well. The video of
me editing this vlog might not be online as
soon as this goes up on the internet, but
it will be online shortly thereafter, and
there will be a link to it in the endscreen.
John, I'll see you on Monday.